in den letzten 150 jahren hat sich die
weltweite durchschnittliche
lebenserwartung ungefähr verdoppelt war
eine gruppe im mittelalter noch ein
todesurteil
so ist sie heute für die meisten
ansonsten gesunden menschen einfach nur
unangenehm mit einer hiv-infektion kann
man heutzutage ein langes und gutes
leben führen und dank impfungen kriegen
wir die meisten erkrankungen erst gar
nicht hepatitis masern und mumps um nur
einige wenige zu nennen
sogar gegen das gefährliche ebola-virus
gibt es jetzt eine impfung alles dank
der modernen medizin
aber vielleicht ist das ja erst der
anfang wenn wir in 150 jahren von den
hier zu den hier gekommen sind wir sehen
dann erst die nächsten 150 jahre aus
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
auf doktor watson
[Musik]
ich war neulich mal wieder bei mini
truck denn als ich das letzte mal da war
hatte ich euch von der spritze ohne
nadel erzielt und das hat euch nicht
losgelassen
anscheinend haben einige von euch angst
vor spritzen ist doch gar nicht
unwahrscheinlich laut dieser studie hier
haben knapp 30 prozent aller reisenden
angst vor der impfung
das kann mehrere gründe haben einer
davon ist die angst vor der nadel selber
die ballone phobie sie müssen sich
überhaupt keine sorgen machen das wird
jetzt nur ein ganz kleines bisschen
pieksen
okay vielleicht etwas übertrieben aber
es ist ja auch schon bald wieder
halloween die angst vor spritzen ist
medizinisch relevant viele leute können
nicht auf die konventionelle art und
weise behandelt werden weil sie
panikattacken bekommen oder in ohnmacht
fallen wenn sie eine spritze bekommen
müssen
deswegen wurde die spritze ohne nadel
erfunden und wie genau funktioniert das
hat mir der promovierte arzneimittel
chemiker tobias schwalbe vom im trakt
ihm erzählt dass ist das projekt projekt
das ist tatsächlich eine spritze ohne
nadel funktioniert wenn man hier einmal
die kappe ab zieht sieht man dass vorne
eine kleine dose ist durch die ein
wasserstrahl mit sehr hohen druck direkt
in die haut appliziert werden kann
das ganze funktioniert schmerzfrei und
es kann sogar ein patient selber durch
einen wasserstrahl der mit hohem druck
in die haut geschossen wird es klingt
nicht besonders schmerzfrei in dem fall
haben wir eine kleinen starken strahl
denn nur wenige bruchteile eines
millimeters in die oberen hautschichten
eindringen muss das reicht schon aus um
unsere immunzellen zu adressieren und
genau diese schichten die sind auch
wenig durchblutet und haben geringere
schmerzrezeptoren nadeln würde jetzt
patient an sich wenn er damit nicht
trainiert ist sich nicht selber setzen
dazu braucht es immer ein arzt und das
ist gefährlich dass sich diese ärzte
oder krankenschwestern pflegepersonal
sich selber gibson könnte mit solchen
laden das will man verhindern dass man
sich mit sachen kontaminiert oder
versehentlich arzneistoffen injiziert
und hinzu kommt auch noch mal früher gab
es ja die spritzen die sterilisiert
worden
vor 60 70 jahren dann kam er ski
einwegspritzen
und das ist noch eine enorme
umweltbelastung im moment wenn wir das
einfach ausklammern könnten und spritzen
nehmen die ohne nadel funktionieren
und ohne diesen kontakten haben dann
können wir also auch sowohl an die
umwelt denken als auch an dieses
gesundheitswesen oder dass man sich
irgendwo tätig sind
dieses modell ist zwar noch für die
einmalige benutzung konzipiert aber
forscher arbeiten bereits an mehrfach
injektoren die durch das einsetzen von
kleinen wechselbaren ampullen wieder
verwendbar wären und die spritze ohne
nadel ist nicht die einzige
technologische neuerung seit knapp 20
jahren auf dem markt und immer häufiger
eingesetzt ist der operation roboter der
windchill das ist ein instrument mit
vielen armen die von einem chirurgen
ferngesteuert werden können
der vorteil dabei die bewegungen können
ruhiger und präziser ausgeführt werden
zum beispiel indem unwillkürliche
bewegungen die das zittern der hände
ausgeglichen werden oder durch die
sogenannte untersetzung dabei wird die
bewegung des operateurs verkleinert
bewegt der arzt seine hand um 5 cm nach
vorne kann der roboter sich zum beispiel
nur um einen zentimeter bewegen wenn man
das vorher so eingestellt hat natürlich
auf diese weise sind viel präzisere
schnitte möglich auch sitzt der chirurg
in einer entspannteren und ergonomische
reinhaltung und kann so längere
operationen aushalten in den meisten
fällen sitzt der chirurg im raum nebenan
aber technisch gesehen kann so ein
roboter von überall auf der welt
gesteuert werden
aus diesem grund wurde das system auch
ursprünglich erfunden ich das us
amerikanische militär wollte eine
möglichkeit haben soldaten in
krisengebieten zu operieren
in zukunft könnte es sein dass seltene
und schwierige operationen von den
weltweit besten chirurgen durchgeführt
werden ohne dass der patient zu diesen
tieren transportiert werden muss dass
das geht wurde schon mehrfach unter
beweis gestellt
[Musik]
präzisions medizin klingt so als würde
sie den da vinci roboter meinen ist aber
eigentlich etwas viel größeres denn
arzneimittel und medizinische methoden
werden heutzutage an einen möglichst
durchschnittlichen körper angepasst
damit möglichst viele menschen von ihnen
profitieren können
leider funktioniert aber jeder körper
ein bisschen anders spricht auf ein
arzneimittel weniger gut an
oder hat vielleicht sogar eine negative
reaktion gegen ein anderes präzisions
medizin sieht den menschen als
individuum und versucht besser zu
verstehen was wirklich helfen könnte in
der realität hilft hier big data das
sind riesige datenmengen die man auf
herkömmliche art und weise nicht mehr
verarbeiten kann
deswegen kommt hier oft künstliche
intelligenz zum einsatz
zuerst werden alle denkbaren daten eines
patienten gesammelt das heißt nicht nur
grundlegende infos wie alter und
geschlecht sondern auch komplexere
informationen wie der krankheitsverlauf
in der vergangenheit das genom oder das
mikro biomasse welche und wie viele
mikroorganismen am und im patienten
leben diese menge an rohdaten soll in
kombination mit der analyse der
aktuellen krankheit auf molekularer
ebene dann eine gezielte behandlung des
patienten ermöglichen
und es gibt nicht nur um die daten eines
einzelnen patienten mindestens genauso
wichtig sind die informationen die man
aus vorkommnissen anderer patienten
gewinnen kann ein tumor hat zum beispiel
eine eigene durchblutung einen eigenen
stoffwechsel und variieren ursachen für
sein wachstum mit hilfe einer datenbank
voller informationen zu verschiedenen
tumoren die bereits bei anderen
patienten aufgetreten sind wird man in
zukunft eine viel genauere diagnose
aufstellen können ein teilgebiet der
präzisions medizin ist die prädiktive
medizin
hier wird versucht krankheiten
vorherzusagen und zu verhindern bevor
sie überhaupt ausbrechen
man kennt das schon von genetischen
krankheit veranlagungen wenn in der
familie eine bestimmte krankheit häufig
vorkommt dann sollte man auf die
symptome dieser krankheit besonders acht
geben und sich regelmäßig darauf
untersuchen lassen
mit hilfe von big data kann man das in
zukunft für noch viel mehr krankheiten
machen
der fitnesstrainer erkennen zb
herzrhythmusstörungen die ernährung sap
weist einen aufzug zuckerhaltigen konsum
hin und die werte in urin und blut
können inzwischen schon alles von
krebserkrankungen bis alzheimer
vorhersagen
bevor also diabetes diagnostiziert wird
kann man vielleicht schon jahre vorher
seine ernährung und lebensweise
umstellen und gar nicht erst krank zu
werden
ich meine man sollte sich sowieso gesund
ernähren aber vielleicht muss man erst
von einem arzt gesagt bekommen dass
einem der fuß abfällt wenn man nicht
sofort mit der schokolade aufhört
in meinem video über organe die auf
einem chip wachsen habe ich ja schon
über induzierte pluripotente stammzellen
gesprochen das video könnt ihr euch hier
oben ansehen
für die entwicklung dieser gab es 2012
den medizin nobelpreis man kann sie aus
dem menschlichen gewebe eines patienten
erzeugen und daraus zum beispiel organe
wachsen lassen die nicht vom immunsystem
abgestoßen werden da sie ja vom selben
körper kommen leider gilt diese methode
aber noch nicht als sicher da die zellen
unkontrolliert wachsen und sich so
tumore bilden können eine methode an der
gerade viel geforscht wird ist die
direkte konversion von zellen einer art
in zellen einer anderen art ohne den
zwischenschritt der induzierten
pluripotenten stammzellen auf diese
weise könnte man gewebe in adam knochen
oder sogar der netzhaut reparieren
obwohl man gar keine zählen dieses
gewebes hat bestimmte stammzellen
scheinen auch die möglichkeit zu haben
den alterungsprozess aufzuhalten oder
sogar umzukehren
im ersten klinischen studien wurde das
bereits 2017 demonstriert das klingt
zugegebenermaßen alles ein bisschen weit
entfernt und man weiß auch überhaupt
noch nicht ob daraus jemals eine echte
anwendung wird aber es geht ja in diesem
video auch um die medizin der zukunft
und deswegen setze ich noch einen drauf
als ich das erste mal im truck war habe
ich mit torben schindler über
nanotechnologien gesprochen
zum beispiel kann man mit hilfe von
eisenoxid nanopartikeln krebszellen
zerstören
diese nanopartikel lassen sich nämlich
gezielt in den krebszellen anreichern
und mit einem magnetfeld erhitzen auf
diese weise kann man gesundes gewebe
verschonen und trifft nur die
krebszellen forscher entwickeln gerade
auch nanokapseln die arzneimittel im
körper zuerst an die richtige stelle
bringen können bevor sie aufbrechen
auslöser dafür ist zum beispiel die
veränderung des ph werts im magen oder
in der nähe eines tumors und natürlich
gibt es auch noch die nano roboter
kurznamen
aktuell können wir schon kleine autos
bauen die auf anderen molekülen herum
fahren können und wir können greifarme
bauen die anderen nanoteilchen präzise
bewegen können wenn man diese beiden
technologien miteinander verbinden
könnte könnte man mit den nano bots im
menschlichen körper herum fahren und
gezielt die zellen verändern die eine
krankheit auslösen oder tumorzellen
heilen oder viren abfangen
die möglichkeiten sind endlos dieses
video wurde unterstützt vom
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung vielen dank dafür
und es ist inzwischen schon das dritte
mal dass ich hier in bakterien durfte
und deswegen wollte ich euch heute mal
zeigen wie der in not track so aussieht
wenn viele von euch waren ja noch gar
nicht hier und hatten die möglichkeit
sich diese mobile ausstellung anzusehen
denn der mini truck geht es um die
zukunft und innovationen an dem gerade
geforscht wird die hoffentlich bald
unser leben verändern werden zb das
wundermaterial graphen das kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch aus meinem ersten
video das ich je gedreht habe
nanotechnologien das habe ich oben
verlinkt den antrag ist generell in so
verschiedene gebiete eingeteilt dass es
zum beispiel zivile sicherheit und hier
geht es generell um dinge die uns
hoffentlich sicherer machen werden es
gibt zum beispiel auch um
quantenkryptographie
wenn wir weiter gehen geht es um
intelligente mobilität das ist diese
ganze wand hier geht es um wasserstoff
autos um elektroautos und es geht um
intelligente scheinwerfer die
hoffentlich die straßen sicherer machen
werden das hier ist juni
das ist ein ko bot ein roboter der für
die mensch maschine kollaboration
gemacht wurde und jetzt so gebaut dass
wenn er einen menschen berührt sofort
aufhört sich zu bewegen damit er keinen
menschen verletzt und hier kann man ganz
gut sehen dass der innotrans wesentlich
breiter ist als ein normaler lkw
denn der kann sich ein und ausklappen
das element auf dem jetzt gerade stehe
das klappt hoch und dieser ganze flügel
hier der kann ein fan und dass das ganze
viel viel kompakter und so kann man hier
von bremen nach berlin nach köln fahren
und die ausstellung kommt einmal quer
durch deutschland wie geht es weiter mit
innovativen materialien zum beispiel
diesen flexiblen material mit dem man
türen öffnen kann oder greifer die von
der bionik inspiriert sind und an der
ecke geht es um nachhaltigkeit das
findet ja mal sehr spannend
und die kann man zum beispiel sehen wie
ein handy aktuell aufgebaut ist und was
da alles für materialien drin sind auch
spannend ein fenster das energie
produzieren kann nämlich mit solarzellen
das aber gleichzeitig auch noch nicht
durchlässt um normales fenster ist das
hier das kennt ihr das ist das
elektronenstrahlen mikroskop das habe
ich schon im zweiten video für den in
new york gezeigt dass wir auch ich oben
verlinkt damit kann man kleinste welten
zeigen und darstellen teilweise elemente
die nur 200 mikrometer groß sind
hier kann man sich anschauen was es
alles in der digitalisierung gibt zum
beispiel gibt es gedruckte elektronik
die aus dem 3d drucker kommt mit der ich
jetzt zum beispiel meine temperatur
messen kann und es gibt eine darstellung
von jüdischen gesetz mit prozessoren die
immer leistungsstärker werden
und jetzt kommt das spannende dieser lkw
hier ist doppelstöckige es gibt das
ganze hier da oben nochmal hier oben
geht es um das wissenschaftsjahr 2009 10
künstliche intelligenz und um virtual
reality wenn irgendwann mal zum innen
schwarz kommt dann könnt ihr virtual
reality spielen und genau das mache ich
jetzt auch
vielen dank fürs zuschauen wie immer
bleibt neugierig
[Musik]